diana is in Cleveland Ohio hi Diana
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi
Rachel how can we help
hi so I like few questions but my main
question is so I there will be two years
in December since I graduated from
college I my parents couldn't afford to
help with college so I had to end up
taking some federal student loans and I
know I want to go to back to grad school
before I get married before I have kids
now that I have time in the momentum to
do it so I'm thinking maybe fall of next
year my question is though is because
I've racked up like some student debt
with my undergrad and then I because my
car gave out on me last second I ended
up getting a used car as well so I have
a car loan as well I wanted to start the
like you know the baby steps but my
question is right now should I devote my
time and effort towards the baby steps
or should I start saving towards grad
school so don't I don't end up getting
more debt how much debt do you have in
your student loans in your car loan
total probably a little under 50k like
10 caves and federal Perkins a little
under 15k is under just federal loans
and then like 21 okay and a car okay
what do you make gross like 50k yeah you
went crazy on your car didn't you yeah
here's uh like I guess like a side part
so okay back to grad school for my nurse
practitioner and your nurse now I'm a
nurse now I cut back actually on the
hours from 40 hours a week to 36 so that
I could go back to waitressing so I
could do nannying because I want to like
use that money and kinda just like cash
or you can make
being a nurse than being a nanny like
well I don't know this is just me
because being discouraged every time I
found that paycheck so much of it was
going towards taxes where I was like
when I'm Manning like you know a psychic
like I guess you have to pay taxes on
the nanny income too we have a federal
income tax in America all income is
taxed it's not tax free income now you
need to go back to being a nurse and
nurse your tail end off and get these
debts cleaned up and then save up and go
back to nurse practitioner school yeah I
was gonna say that I was say Dianna make
sure I mean in the whole car situation
you can chime in she saw the car and all
of that but when it comes to your
schooling yes go back
stick with nursing and then waitress at
night no just nurse but but yeah but you
can waitress at night if she doesn't
have a shift a nursing shift you can get
all shift your nursing to pay off debt
you can work 80 hours a week as a nurse
I don't work in the medical field but I
know that you can take extra jobs they
hump debt that's what I'm saying
we're GEX try do what you can we're next
I as a nurse you'll make more than
waitressing or nannying okay fair
totally fair and then pay off the debt
and then your emergency fund and then
save it for grad school but car go you
yeah it's okay I mean the thing is you
make more being a nurse and yes you get
taxed more when you make more but that's
how the income tax works you don't get
away from that and so I know don't be a
waitress and don't be a nanny be a nurse
you make twice as much doing that if you
do anything else and go to work in 80
hours a week and clean up your mess you
can you can be debt-free probably in a
year and a half and then you can save up
the money and go to you can even keep
the car and be dead for any a year and a
half but if you want to go to grad
school debt-free save up and pay cash
for it and you'll be able to do that
because you have a fabulous career field
and chosen a fabulous career field
because you're always gonna be able to
find a job and you know always work
extras yes that's fair and and I hear
this a lot from younger people that they
think once I get married or African
then I don't have those options anymore
but you still do so I would make it a
priority to clean up your mess now pause
a little bit on grad school too you can
save up and pay for and even if you're
married you can still go to grad school
even when you have kids does it make it
a little bit more you know difficult
sure there's some logistics there but
you can still go back so like that's
always out there don't feel like this
urgency that you have to do it in the
next if you want me to know about it
though go so you're calling get your
five thousand on car industry than that
would that would speed up yeah how fast
you get to go to be debt-free and how
fast you can be have the money to go on
to grad school nurse practitioners are
great that's a great thing to go get I'm
with you on your path I just want you to
readjust how you're getting at your path